if you guys were falling on the vlog
yesterday [ __ ] Bobby Madden let me
see this [ __ ] knee right you're just
going over there
Oh with what oh yeah I'm like Bobby's
legs no there's nothing in there I'm
like if there's something in there I'm
like if I just get to the office then
use a paper clip show Gavin there you go
that's what's really in your career
you know I think reputation is based on
truth and so in today's world there's
nowhere to hide instead of hiring a PR
person in 1994 and getting the right
articles I think it's just delivering
crush it for your employees crush it for
your clients and and fundamentally give
without expectation you know go give a
keynote at a college with no expectation
answer those 10 emails of people
reaching out to you that have nothing to
offer you
and just give because you they actually
may have a ton to offer you what I love
is that reputation is becoming a more
transparent game and so the only way to
build the reputation is to do the right
things so over-deliver
for the ones that have something or the
ones that don't have something way too
many entrepreneurs are way to calculate
it about what's in it for me if you can
reverse that and think about what's in
it for them you'll find out that a lot
of things are in it for you
it's understand that you're sitting in
the room of greatness and this will be
studied for decades to come and you'll
be an old grandma and I'll be like yes
and and then I colored my hair all sorts
of colors one day and then he was
recording that thing and Facebook good
morning Kendall Big Ups to you Tyler
less ups for you just wanna tell
everybody
today Wednesday yes it's a hump day
thing is such [ __ ] like hump day
like oh we're gonna get over to hump and
it's gonna get awesome because the
weekend is what you have to escape to
love a day that means that you're almost
to the weekend makes no [ __ ] sense
64% of your life is spent on working do
something about it if you hate it [ __ ]
hump day love every day so hey I just
want to give a big shout out to all the
artists that and there's some more can
you get them all can you get some of
them Tyler you know big shots all the
artists that make portraits of me like
it is ridiculously humbling there's a
big one out there it's crazy humbling
there's another one can you get the big
one out there it's crazy humbling here's
the thing I have no idea really what to
deal with it I think it's kind of weird
and more I'm thinking about it like it
feels super like douchey in some ways
that's cool right so here's what I'm
doing I'm gonna sign these four amazing
pcs or amazing pieces I'm doing this
video because I don't want to disrespect
the artists that gave me huge love but I
think they have a better home
I would have liked I love my Macho Man
Randy Savage
no Macho Man Randy Savage I love my
Carmello thing I love my stuff but my
own face in my own office listen I love
myself but like look I can't I can't
have this [ __ ] around anymore so so [ __ ]
about my pops all day cuz I gotta give
that to him but like just this is the
official video it's real simple like if
you're gonna send me a porch in my thing
awesome and I'm gonna give you even more
love because I'm gonna sign them and
then give them away on social and tag
you so artists will get love in the
future but like like ah if you're making
a portrait with the hope that it's gonna
be like in my office or in my home and
that gives you love I don't want to make
that assumption anymore cuz I don't need
them I don't mean like I don't I don't I
feel weird I don't want I want portraits
of me in my [ __ ] offices in my home
you agree right it's weird like alright
cool so here we go so this one's awesome
sign away it's not super well done all
right
no I'm good now here we go
separate pieces of content so that's
that done that I'm here supple confident
giving this away dude you can't talk to
Dirac he said he's an adjective now what
is it actually when people say that they
have a d-roc is that what is that what
is that drug guys you don't even
understand yeah what is it
banned English what is it is it both
places right but it's wrong Trulia now
right it's Lloyd
yes for you please Biddy Rocking Jim
Beam Irving let the more people laugh
and brother you won like [ __ ] little
reasons we know you guys are all upset I
get it let's create a plan
so this is the new video yeah
the number one mistake that people are
making in life today and it's and it's
just so unbelievably obvious is they're
living life in the middle you know 99.9
percent of the people that watch or
listen to this content are living in the
middle there they're hedging and making
excuses and justifying why they are not
100% happy it's because like every other
person out there besides a few select
people they are living in this middle
ground and I just say [ __ ] the middle
and when I think about how you win in
business and entrepreneurship but most
of all in life it's by understanding the
macro and micro opportunities and
executions if you really understand how
to break through how to be in that zone
how to really really really win the game
it comes down to a strategy that looks
like this are you balancing your ego
with your humility are you balancing
your ego with your humility
do you Iike lieth inc that you're the
greatest of all time and you can do it
and that also you're a piece of [ __ ] and
nobody cares when you're gone bye guys
I'll be right there just gonna catch up
in a couple things it's actually binary
you either talk about you question my
biggest strength is I'm narrow as [ __ ]
you know as people that have hate you
know know who I am
know that one of the great things that
people bring up about me is that I see
cuz I read everything you're repetitive
I'm like good
yeah I'm like what do you want me to
make up [ __ ] I'm like I'm lucky that I
used my repetitive strategy on a
changing world voice is not repetitive I
promise you all my insights and ability
if me making voice come through my
filter not me chasing voice
right
I'm the same of forever
Spotify following because he's had one
for about three months
there's a there's three ways to build
[ __ ] one collaborations use somebody
else's plat like this video you're
making right now you'll be able to
leverage my equity in some ways for it
to be more viewed than that
so collaborations aren't incredible you
should be searching fishing hashtags and
anybody pretty cool with a lot of
followers you need to be thinking about
how you can do something co-signing
collaborations number two is ads like
guys ads are underpriced
if you have the luxury of having money
which it may or may not but Facebook and
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram ads
or underpriced they're doing ads for the
spot alert a hundred percent and number
three a complete commitment to every
other place you have attention if you go
to my Instagram profile right now my
default URL is a link to my podcast
because right this second I've decided
that's most important the signature of
your email I will tell you the signature
of your email is one of the sneakiest
Real Estate's that nobody uses yeah so
like he should put his his Spotify
playlist if that's the most important
the URL on your Twitter your fate your
Instagram
using every other platform to drive
awareness to it
you enjoyed it soaking it in right photo
oh yeah I need to use it better
if you guys want to
reunion